العربيه هي منبر عربي مهم جدا
وقناه يتابعونها السعوديين والعرب بشكل
مكثف
ونعتقد انها رسالتنا سوف تصل للسعوديين
والعالم العربي من خلال هذا المنبر
الى ما قدرت بيروت وين رايح يا ابو عمار
قلتلهم معنا فلسطين
واتكلمنا في الموضوع وطلعت على بغداد
دقيقه
اعتقد انه يجب اولا تجنب اثاره ما يمكن ان
يضع الشعوب وخاصه الاديان في مواجهه بعضها
مستعدون للمبادره بشراكه جديده مبنيه على
الاحترام المتبادل والمصالح المشتركه هل
تتوقع ان تصدر تهديدات معينه لاحقا يعني
اتوقع ان يقوم بعض الذين ضللوه في تحريضه
لانهم كانوا من اقرب المقربين
يحاول اكتساب تحالفات لحكومته يعني هو
بالاساس يحاول اكتساب ناس الحكومه نحتاجك
في مقابله لنا قبل ايام
حاصروا كل القنوات التجاريه الشاب قال
كلمته عند تم سحب الثقه من هذه الحكومه
وخرج في ميدان الشهداء الطريقه التي
تعاملت بها حتى نجحت بكل هذه السنوات
لا انفسنا